si retrocediéramos el reloj unos 70
millones de años veríamos dinosaurios
deambulando por la tierra y esta es una
muy buena imagen de un dinosaurio
disfrutando de una puesta de sol en la
playa pero desafortunadamente para los
dinosaurios hace unos 65 millones de
años creemos que un gran meteorito
golpeó la tierra y esencialmente
aniquiló a los dinosaurios y
probablemente eliminó a un montón de
otras especies también ya que pueden
imaginar que la onda de choque en sí
misma exterminaría a muchísimas especies
y luego vendría un tsunami de tamaño
inimaginable que envolvería a los
continentes por un periodo de tiempo y
luego habría hollín que se elevaría en
el aire y tal vez haría imposible que la
mayoría de las especies de plantas
sobrevivieron ya que bloquearía toda la
luz solar y así en un entorno como éste
podríamos imaginar que un animal como
éste estaría bien adaptado para
sobrevivir se oculta bajo tierra tal vez
pueda hibernar de alguna manera por lo
que no necesita alimentos durante largos
periodos de tiempo tal vez tiene su
propio escondrijo de comida
o de algún lugar y por eso creemos que
nuestros ancestros tremendamente
antiguos después de este evento de
extinción masiva podrían haber sido algo
así una especie de roedor con aspecto de
topo que estaba protegido de toda esta
locura que sucedía en la superficie
porque les gustaba estar bajo tierra
tener toda su comida cerca de ellos y
tal vez podrían hibernar de alguna
manera así que podemos imaginar que una
vez que todo se calmó hace quién sabe
cuántos cientos de años miles de años
incluso millones de años algunos de los
descendientes de este individuo
comenzaron a sacar la cabeza del suelo y
dijeron mira hay comida en los árboles
no hay nadie más en los árboles y los
árboles son un buen lugar para alejarse
de algunos de los otros depredadores que
sobrevivieron a este evento de extinción
masiva y algunos de estos descendientes
que eran buenos para trepar árboles
dijeron oye probemos esto del árbol y
entonces comenzó a ver cierta forma de
selección para los descendientes de este
roedor que podría trepar bien a los
árboles pudieron encontrar comida donde
sus antepasados no pudieron
podrían encontrar protección en los
árboles donde sus antepasados no
pudieron y entonces podríamos imaginar
que un subconjunto de los descendientes
de este individuo evolucionaron en algo
que podría haberse parecido a este otro
individuo y todas las fotos que les
muestro son de animales modernos excepto
por supuesto el dinosaurio estoy segura
de que esta foto fue de alguna manera
editada este es un lémur ido pero
muestro esta imagen por que así podrían
haberse visto algunos de estos primates
primitivos como un lémur ido trepa a los
árboles y parece que está adaptando una
mano aquí para trepar a los árboles pero
también tienen cualidades del roedor
pero esta es por supuesto una versión
moderna del mismo entonces el ancestro
muy antiguo de este le munido podría
haber sido ese primate primitivo o esa
especie de primate primitivo que fue
descendiente de los roedores que se
atrevieron a trepar a estos árboles para
encontrar algo de comida y luego algunos
de sus descendientes podrían haber
tenido las adaptaciones correctas
haber encontrado su propio nicho en los
ecosistemas correctos y se habrían
convertido en monos una vez más este es
un mono moderno pero podríamos imaginar
algún tipo de mono primitivo y luego
algunos de los descendientes de esos
monos primitivos finalmente se
convirtieron en estos monos modernos
pero algunos de ellos crecieron en
tamaño pasaron más tiempo fuera de los
árboles perdieron su cola ya no la
requerían para equilibrarse y quizá no
era bueno tenerla porque alguien más
podría agarrarla durante una pelea o
algo así y evolucionaron en simios en
particular como grandes simios entonces
algunos de los grandes simios son los
gorilas y los chimpancés y los
antepasados de los grandes simios
también fueron antepasados de la
humanidad así que déjenme volver a
revisar esta línea de tiempo para que no
nos confundamos repasaré lo que acabamos
de mencionar entonces antes de este
evento de extinción masiva hace 65
millones de años había todos estos tipos
de especies aquí quizá esto de aquí
arriba
si hablamos de especies era el
tiranosaurio rex
hay un montón de especies que podríamos
enumerar aquí pero después de ese evento
de extinción masiva ese fue el punto
final para muchísimas especies excepto
tal vez para esta primitiva especie de
roedores parecidos a topos quizá muchos
de ellos murieron en este evento pero
suficientes de ellos sobrevivieron
porque estaban bajo tierra o en algún
lugar correcto o estaban en alguna
montaña en algún lugar quién sabe dónde
estaban y algunos de ellos fueron
capaces de evolucionar a primates
primitivos y una vez más estas son
imágenes de versiones modernas de
primates primitivos y primitivos no
necesariamente significa peor porque
obviamente estas especies incluso en el
mundo de hoy tienen un nicho para sí
mismos son capaces de encontrar
alimentos y reproducirse de manera que
no se meten con nadie y nadie se mete
con ellos cuando hablo de primates
primitivos solo estoy hablando de una
especie de primate ancestral tal vez
algo que no exista actualmente aunque
tal vez algunos de sus descendientes se
parezcan mucho a él
de todos modos algunos de esos primates
evolucionaron en monos primitivos
algunos de los descendientes de esos
monos primitivos se convirtieron en
monos modernos les pongo una m de monos
modernos algunos de ellos evolucionaron
en simios primitivos y los simios tienen
características particulares que se
asemejan a los monos pero no tienen cola
y son más grandes que la mayoría de los
monos y así estos simios primitivos
algunos de sus descendientes son los
gorilas modernos en algún momento se
separaron algunos de sus descendientes
son ancestros tanto de los chimpancés
modernos como de los seres humanos y
pensamos al ver la evidencia de adn
creemos que esta separación ocurrió aquí
y la evidencia fósil sugiere que fue
hace unos 7 millones de años
esa es nuestra mejor estimación de
cuando nosotros los seres humanos
tuvimos un antepasado común con los
chimpancés ahora tenemos ese ancestro
común algunos de los descendientes de
ese ancestro común se convirtieron en
chimpancés modernos y algunos de ellos
es porque exploraron el ecosistema
correcto en donde era más ventajoso
hacerlo comenzaron a caminar sobre dos
patas y el fósil más famoso de esto es
el fósil australopithecus de lucy que
existió hace 3.2 millones de años y se
descubrió más recientemente tiene 3.2
millones de años de edad entonces todo
el género y el género es una especie de
nivel de categorización por arriba de
las especies todo el género de
australopithecus existió hace 4 o 2
millones de años no podemos estar
seguros ya que aún podemos encontrar un
fósil que sea más antiguo que esto tal
vez más reciente que esto y una
referencia que dice que quizá hace un
millón de años pero más o menos el fósil
de lucy que es el fósil de
australopithecus mejor establecido tiene
aproximadamente 3 millones de años y
esta es una reconstrucción de lucy así
que probablemente así se veía lucy y una
vez más habían muchas luces no existía
solo una luz y todos somos descendientes
de luz
ni siquiera está claro si descendemos
directamente del australopithecus
podríamos ser una especie de primo o un
género de primos el género es la
categoría justo por encima de la especie
entonces si avanzamos un poco más en el
tiempo hacia unos 2.3 a 1.4 millones de
años
vemos fósiles que están erguidos el
tamaño del cerebro es más grande porque
si nos fijamos en los fósiles de
australopithecus están erguidos pero su
capacidad craneal no es tan diferente a
la de los chimpancés si avanzamos
rápidamente a 2.3 millones o 1.4
millones de años atrás comenzamos a ver
fósiles erguidos cuya capacidad craneal
ha crecido y encontramos herramientas de
piedra primitivas alrededor de los
fósiles socios y por eso creemos que
estos son uno de los primeros así es
como lo categorizamos estos son algunos
de los primeros fósiles que
categorizamos como pertenecientes al
mismo género que el nuestro
género es como como solo significa
hombre entonces es el grupo justo encima
de la especie del hombre y los llamamos
similares al hombre porque parece que
están empezando a hacer herramientas de
piedra primitivas estaban erguidos como
nosotros y tenían capacidades craneales
más grandes que los fósiles de
australopithecus o los chimpancés
modernos y una vez más no sabemos si el
homo habilis que literalmente significa
homo hombre y habilis hábil porque al
parecer le gustaba hacer herramientas y
cosas por el estilo no sabemos si el
homo habilis es un descendiente de la
especie de luz y los australopithecus o
quizá una especie de primo tal vez ambos
son descendientes de algún antepasado
común no estamos muy seguros luego
avanzamos un poco más estamos hablando
ahora de hace 1.8 a 1.38 millones de
años y comenzamos a ver fósiles cuya
capacidad craneal es más grande que la
del homo habilis acercándose en tamaño a
lo que consideramos como la capacidad
craneal de una persona moderna al menos
en relación con el tamaño del cuerpo
y este es el homo erectus no sabemos si
el homo erectus es descendiente del homo
habilis quizá tengan un ancestro común
quien sabe por la evidencia fósil parece
que especialmente en este rango de aquí
hubo una superposición en donde
existieron al mismo tiempo el homo
erectus y el homo habilis ahora
avanzamos un poco más pensamos que hace
600 mil a 300 mil años y nuevamente
todos estos datos se modifican a medida
que mejoramos en la búsqueda de nuevos
fósiles o interpretando los fósiles que
ya tenemos en la evidencia de adn o lo
que sea hace unos 600 mil a 300 mil años
aparecieron los neandertales y los
neandertales pertenecen al mismo género
que los humanos así que son homo
neandertales esto sigue siendo parte de
homo y una equivocación común es pensar
que los neandertales sean una versión
más primitiva de los humanos como si de
cierta forma ellos fueran cavernícolas y
nosotros hombres modernos pero esto no
es así se cree que los neandertales son
una especie prima la nuestra
o sea que tenemos un ancestro común o
que son una subespecie de la nuestra
algunos piensan que pudieron
reproducirse con los homo sapiens y
quizá algunos o varios de nosotros
tengamos genes de neandertal y no hay
nada de que avergonzarse simplemente es
algo lamentable que la cultura popular
les haya dado tan mala reputación a los
neandertales esta es una representación
de una cabeza de neandertal de hecho
ellos tenían una gran capacidad craneal
aunque algunos científicos inventan
diversas razones del por qué pensamos
que pudieron ser más primitivos que el
homo sapiens pero quién sabe
no sabemos aprendemos cosas nuevas cada
día pero por supuesto el objetivo de
todo esto es hablar sobre cómo los
humanos aparecieron en este planeta y
los primeros fósiles humanos que
encontramos eran de hace 200.000 años y
recuerden que pertenecemos al género
homo por lo que ahora encontramos algo
que se parece mucho a nosotros al menos
anatómicamente no podemos estudiar su
comportamiento y todo lo demás por lo
que ahora llegamos al homo sapiens
como de nuevo significa hombre y la
parte sapiens significa pensante podemos
debatir si este es un título apropiado
para nuestra especie pero es el hombre
pensante los neandertales fueron una
especie prima la nuestra durante mucho
de este tiempo especialmente una vez que
apareció el homo sapiens y quizá el homo
sapiens apareció antes pero no hemos
descubierto evidencia fósil de esto o
quizá ambos habitaron el planeta al
mismo tiempo quizás se reprodujeron
entre ellos pero los neandertales
desaparecieron hace 30 mil años quizá
algo de ellos se mezcló con el homo
sapiens cuando se reprodujeron con ellos
o quizás sólo fueron exterminados porque
peleaban por el mismo ecosistema y aquí
puse un pequeño ejemplo de homo sapiens
bueno yo supongo que muchos de los que
están viendo este vídeo son homo sapiens
pero aquí está mi pequeño ejemplo aunque
quizá podríamos debatir que tan buen
ejemplo de nuestra especie son